how do you feel that the female leads
differ in Indian cinema versus the
female leads that are in American cinema
what type of personality traits I think
it depends on the film's itself a lot of
the Bollywood movies are musicals so I
feel that their heroines are more
glamorous and but sometimes depending on
if it's a drama they can be unglamorous
and they do play the you know the
character and I think there's a
difference between bollywood an Indian
cinema where Indian cinema focuses more
on the everyday people and their stories
more than this case sorry schism of the
Bollywood but it's fine like you know it
is nothing wrong in volume it's fine lot
of in this lot of regional films as well
like this tamil malayalam films
signaling films in the South Asian
region and i love it all and I love
Hollywood movies as well because that's
what I do i add more on a Hollywood TV
and film and I think follow it is like
the heroines more they may prepare more
for the character that they're playing
then for the glamour so but i think what
is not wrong i think it's what it is
what it is so it's both i enjoy both
films
let seems as if Bollywood stars are
treated basically as royalty and there's
such an exuberant fan base for them with
great power comes great responsibility
so what would you say to your fans that
probably hang on every word and watch
your tweets and and are very dependent
on what you think I would say to take
responsibility for your own actions
just-joan sometimes yeah you can't help
but be in your circumstance but whatever
happens that know that you're strong
that you don't have to resort to drink
or drugs or stuff like that that you can
get through things talk to people just
know we all know what's going on around
you and it's okay to be moderate like
have wine once in a while you know
that's why I mix your own judgment but
just be responsible for yourself and
just enjoy life and just keep moving
forward
love life that's excellent thank you oh
well written by Smith